[Music]  when Tupac was shot and killed it really  resonated that things are really  dangerous you heard the same things we  all heard at the time in the press that  one side was involved in the death of  the other side and then they came back  and retaliated there were so many rumors  and things for years you know I was more  concerned just about the well-being of  my artisan and also myself and my family  do you stop and think Shawn about what  biggie would be doing today 20 years  later where his career would be who he  would be alongside you it's incomplete  you know without him being there and it  makes you wonder like how would this  constant be you know he was here like  Howard what direction would rap go into  [Music]